obviously everyone knows that you've
produced some of the greatest records
ever but
i the way i see that is you just brought
out the best
in a lot of interesting
artists and so
in order to bring out the best in them
you have to
understand them you have to
hear the music of their soul
hopefully not being too romantic here
but just like
is there
something you can say
of how difficult that is if there's a
process
if there's tricks
if it's luck
um i think it's it starts with this
again coming in blank like not having
any preconceived ideas
being open and really listening
listening and not
thinking about what you're going to say
next or what your opinion is or any you
know not
basically being a recorder and just
hearing what comes in
and then once you hear what comes in
processing that information
and i'm trying our best to do that
without any of the beliefs that we might
have
to impact what that is
you know if i if i ask you a question i
don't want to hear what i don't want to
listen to you and have any reaction
happening when you're speaking
and want to be as
neutral as possible for me for
to be my goal is is
is not to form an opinion it's to
understand
so if anything
i would draw you out further and just
ask questions
to really understand
and if you say or if you say something
that i um
that somehow uh triggers me in a way
that
that's a you know i wonder how
he came to that i would i would i
wouldn't challenge you i would ask like
how did you find that you know how did
you get to that place
from a place of curiosity you would try
to figure out yeah i want to understand
who the person is and through
questioning we can usually get there or
through
just spending time together you find out
who the person is
what about finding out and figuring out
how to then take the next steps of
bringing out the best in them
like uh is it just trial and error like
let's try this it's definitely trial and
error it's always trial and error
are you afraid of making a mistake like
let's let's add this instrument let's
remove this instrument let's try to add
this line let's remove this line let's
try and let's
let's be open it's one of the one of the
uh
there we don't really have rules but one
of the agreements in the studio is
any idea that anyone has
will always
demonstrate it we'll always try it
because i can describe to you an idea
and you can think
that's terrible idea let's not do that
and then i can play you the idea and
then you can say oh that's really good
and it's completely different because we
when we hear when we're told something
we have to
imagine what that is
and the way you see something and
imagine it the way i see something and
imagine are completely different so you
say a thing and now there's two humans
that play that thing in their mind
differently in their imagination
and then there's a cool creative step
and when you actually do it to see how
it differs in the imagination and then
the difference or the commonality will
be like an exciting little discovery
together well so many so many uh groups
of people making things together in a
room
one person will suggest something and
someone else in the room said that that
doesn't sound like a good idea let's not
do that and then they move on
uh the testing of every idea is really
important and that's how you get to see
oh that's not at all what i thought it
was going to be happens to me all the
time i know because
someone will suggest why don't we do it
like this and i'll think
that sounds bad and then i'll think okay
let's try it and then we hear it and
then you know eight times out of ten
it's nothing like i imagined and great
and you try not to have an ego about the
fact that you thought it was not a good
idea in your head
there can't be any
ego in this it doesn't uh
if if if everyone's
there with the purpose of making the
best thing we can
there's nothing else you know there are
no um there can't be any boundaries to
that
you